every day we are encountering thousands
and thousands of pathogen and it turns
out our body's immune system can mount a
defense response against them so how
does our immune system does that one of
the component of our immune system is
b-cell against the pathogenic antigens
b-cells produce antibodies actually B
cells get differentiated into antibody
secreting plasma cells now these plasma
cells can specifically mount immune
response against a pathogenic antigen so
there are thousands of antigens could be
produced by a single pathogen itself and
imagine there are so many pathogens and
our immune system need to be diverse in
terms of creating new versions of
antibodies such that it can encounter
the pathogenic antigens so this
diversity is required for antibody
production question is how does this
diversity achieved in terms of antibody
production or how does diverse
antibodies with different affinity and
avidity for a particular antigen is
created and the answer lies in a genetic
recombination which happens in the anti
antibody light chain and heavy chain
genes so in this video we'll talk about
vdj recombination it turns out we have
51 3 27 t and 6j gene segments so not so
the simple thing is we don't have one
gene segment for heavy chain or the
light chain of the antibodies we have
multiple gene segments now what is the
importance of having so many different
segments it turns out this several
segments could be joined in a sequence
for example this diversity and J
segments can join together by a
recombination process known as DJ
recombination
further the v-d-j these segments could
be joined in really jury combination
process and thereby can create a
different transcript depending upon
which combinations they're combining and
that can give rise to antibodies heavy
chain now in a compete in a
communitarian manner huge diversity
could be produced itself in the heavy
chain forget about the light chain for a
moment but itself in the heavy chain
using a combinatorial code a plasma cell
can produce huge variety of antibodies
now we talk about a light chain light
chin doesn't have the J segment so
doesn't have the diversity segment I'm
sorry but it has the V and J segments
which could be recombining together by
feature recombination to give rise to
specific transcript which can form
specific light chain segments now not
only P cells or B cell receptors or
antibodies undergoes this kind of
recombination to produce diversity it
turns out that P cell receptor and T
cell receptor all undergoes this kind of
recombination to produce the P cell
receptor or T cell receptor now vdj
recombination is dependent upon two
different components first the
recombination signal sequence present in
the gene segments second the recombinase
enzyme that helps in recombination so it
turns out after every gene segments
there are small signal sequences these
signal sequences are either known as one
turn sequences or to turn sequences now
wantem sequences have 12 base pairs
spacer in between them but as to turn
has 23 base pair spacers between them
and there is a joining rule between
these
jeans segments and these recombination
signal sequences the rule says that
opposite turns can join together for
example a 1/10 sequence can join with a
two turned sequence but the similar ones
cannot join with each other this ensures
that the gene segments recombine in a
proper order and also the internal
recombination between itself let's say
the diversity segment or itself between
the joining segments cannot happen so
the intra segmental recombination cannot
happen by following this rule so which
is a clever way of designing this
recombination system that evolved
throughout time now let's talk about the
enzymes which are necessary for this
recombination process as expected since
it's a recombination process there
should be specific recombinase so there
are two recombinase of rag one which is
known as recombinase associated gene
that problem their product give rise to
rag1 and rag2 recombinases which are
most important recombinases for pdj
recombination apart from that terminal
deoxynucleotidyl transferase or T DT is
also involved in this process
now P cell development starts in the
bone marrow right after its development
in the bone marrow it moves to the lymph
node where it gets matured and learn how
to encounter an encounter pathogens now
inside the bone marrow
there are vascular niche an industrial
niche where several stages of the B
cells could be found let us look at
which stage of the p0 this VD j
recombination is taking place so in
early in pre-pro b-cells stage the pre
pro b-cell gets attached to the bone
marrow stromal cell
why and one important interaction is a
safe and seek it and also it expresses
several chemokine receptors such as CX
CL 12 receptor so all these signals give
rise to DJ recombination at this
particular point of time of the heavy
chain later when it progressed to early
probl stage then interleukin derived
from the stroma tell cells to give rise
to specific signaling that helps in
total vdj recombination process other
than these external signals the external
signals impinge upon internal signals
onto internal transcription factors
which helps in this process maybe by
producing the recombinases gene or many
other aspects of the recombination so we
look at what happens when il7 mediated
signaling comes and how does the b-cell
how does the immature b-cell read that
signal so here is IL 7 i all seven give
rise to jak-stat mediated signaling
which allow transcription which allow
the activation of several transcription
factors like eb f1 pax 5 etc all of
these help in vdj recombination or
several aspects of vdj recombination so
let's just look at quickly at the
mechanism of vdj recombination so the
first step of the recombination is the
enzyme so rag1 and rag2
should recognize the proper
recombination signal sequence on the vdj
gene segment so here you understand
there is let's say we take a simple
example of a light chain gene segments
where we have V and J so here our
recombination associated proteins rag1
and rag2 is recognizing the signal
sequences after that these enzyme
use a DNA looping mechanism by which
this one turn and to turn RSS are paired
inside the active site of these enzymes
and there is a cleavage of these one
single strand by rag1 and rag2 after
that these cleavage sequences form hair
pins with each other and this is
followed by a double stranded DNA break
by rag1 and rag2 so when the
double-stranded DNA break occurs it need
to be joined together and that joining
process happens by NH EJ mediated
mechanism where Kuh 70 or kuwaiti binds
to it followed by the binding of artemis
DNA PK and X are cc 4 etc enzymes of all
the NH EJ mechanism which give rise to
joining of these gene segments and it
now the mRNA would be produced from this
gene segment which would be later
translated to give rise to the light
chain now we talk about a little bit how
this diversity could arise in terms of
after vdj recombination or what are the
mechanism of producing antibody
diversity so it turns out multiple jam
line gene segments are there that we
looked at so there is at least 51 v 27 D
and 6 J chains that means possible
combinations that could be achieved by
using a community combination is at
least more than rough about 8,000 apart
from that there is a junction of
flexibility that means whenever there is
a double-stranded break when the
segments joined together there is a
flexibility in this joining process not
only there is a junction of flexibility
whenever the double strand breaks happen
there could be new nucleotide addition
to it which is which accounts for
diversity
after all these things there is a
process known as somatic hypermutation
which creates even more diverse
antibodies so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked my video very quick
thumbs up don't forget to like here's a
tank